der film soll was geht ab es geht weiter
mit
wir leben
ich bin richtig aufgeregt weil ich nicht
weiß ob irgendjemand gleich nach
wahrscheinlichkeit wieder im schnitt die
helligkeit mit hallo erstmal nach oben
dass da nicht sprinten und sogar chillen
alles okay dass ich das erde
sao paulo wieder ein soccerfeld verleiht
schlag am besten so ein bisschen gras
kaputt ist hier so so ein bisschen samen
habe ich habe zwei stück so wurden die
nächsten wolle bekomme hier mit lang
hier gern ich kannte nicht ich bin ruhig
bringt ja auch nicht kommen wir gehen
hier vorne hin da vorne da es steht
sogar schon eine werkbank
ich habe außerdem springt das steht
sogar schon eine werk von gesetzen
müssen uns nicht verkraften
perfekt das war gut für uns aber nur ja
jetzt ist halt die frage wie sieht das
aus mit ich frag mich wie ich mit essen
aussieht wie viele jahre genau doch
leben sind hier tiere wurde hier schon
in der ganzen gegend wurde hier schon
mega viel gefahren
fata hol di maría holt immer weiter
heute weitermachen immer ebene
spitzhacke um schon mal steine zu holen
für die gegenstände die wir brauchen
wenn euch waren einfach in der zeit
weiter holz ist keine server wir sind
said bis jetzt so es ist bis jetzt ist
alles gut wir sind gut drauf wären gute
laune
bis jetzt ist noch alles gut wir hoffen
halt wirklich dass uns keiner irgendwie
hinterher joint ich sehe hier und auch
gerade wieder nichts wahrscheinlich habe
ich mir alles ein bisschen heller wieder
gedreht dass ihr das natürlich sehen
können wenn ihr das tagsüber schaut aber
wir spielen halt gerade auch um 16 uhr
genau so dass gerade ist der server
online gegangen und wir versuchen
wirklich dass uns keiner nachschauen
also dass uns jetzt wird erst mal kippen
können wir wissen nämlich schon das
wahrscheinlich einige schon führend sind
beziehungsweise schon sehr sehr gut mit
dabei sind die halt am anfang in der
mitte waren und so weiter das waren wir
halt nicht deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen equippen hier
und dass derzeit die taktik in dieser
folge also wir haben uns die ziele
gesetzt dass wir erstmal puls ton geben
nicht viel weiter als ob grad macht wird
er deswegen das ist ja auch so eine
sache
was als ob es gerade nacht wird alltag
um einen apfel vom baum gefallen okay
ich mache uns beiden man schwert erst
mal mama bretter okay ich habe schwer
für dich ich schmeiße dass man dahin
kann sticks zu schmeißen uns noch mehr
gegenstände an der six wird dann hier
kannst du steckst mitbewerber hergang
gegangen jetzt wär halt ganz fresh
erwarte ich habe all times sorge wenn
ich auch noch eine schaufel mache ich
uns beide noch eben lässig so da jetzt
würde ich gern irgendwie mal nach essen
aus schon die weil diese links hier mit
diesen den work travel das wollen wir
auch für freie ebene gehen weil wenn ihr
zwischen herrn ob es vielleicht nicht
sogar mit mops das heißt ja wenn monster
kommen oder so dass man hier lang
ok also ich habe einen apfel zumindest
das heißt ich habe jetzt ein hunger
balken insgesamt verloren wir dürfen
halt nahezu so wenig wie möglich
irgendwie springen
das heißt ja ja ich habe anderthalb
verloren gerade im osten verloren hat
schon zwei fälle ok wir müssen das echt
aber sollten ja irgendwie mal
wiederkommen oder musik da müssen auch
basieren schwein zu schwein diesen
schweinen ok safe töten erst mal ich geh
auch mal darunter und immer noch unter
dem paar steine mit bitte hier seine
höhle ich höre von irgendwo eine spinne
habe ich gerade gehört wir sind auch
abgebaute steine
das ist ihr ding du minecraft nun ja ich
bin echt genug
ich bin ein richtiger nur wir können wir
beide nichts eigentlich verstanden hast
du mich viele wir brauchen 18 ofen weil
wir hier einfach ein bisschen was weg
balala da hierzu paar steine diese
spinne kann es seien ja de rome ist ein
spinner
okay okay sie wie sieht mich jetzt an
hab die spinne tot ohne irgendwas zu
verlieren von redaktionen ja
wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt alles dazu
auch noch genau jetzt so manegold leiter
so ein scheiß da ja gut er wird schon
zweieinhalb verloren 2 einhalten müssen
unbedingt wiederfinden ich habe zwei
verloren ja komm lass mal hier lang
ich mach mal kurz den ton bisschen
leiser wegen regen auch retter auf die
andere seite gehen kommen mit zurück zum
spiel
ich hätte fast auf quitt gedrückt auch
nicht so schlimm gewesen aber was ist
mit dem wasser aber noch vor der weg
laufen einfach ja scheiße jetzt kommt
regen und dunkel so ein kack einfach
sehr mächtig
scheiße da eine höhle da ist ein hasen
gibt zarte fleisch rabbit ich habe ihn
hat ihn wie so ein mob alter n bisschen
schlaf ich glaub scheiden lasse ich aber
sagen ob auf oder ich kann die elektrik
nicht sehen was immer sugar kane ist
links salón scharf okay das red wings
ich bin hier rechts hier ist schon mal
eine höhle da kann man rein theoretisch
reihen aber wir brauchen erst war da
oben ist auch noch ein schaf der wolga
fleisch und wolle
ich habe auch schon fleisch okay ich
habe auch hier sind noch viel mehr
schaffen sie es für mich aber ich komme
in deine richtung okay hier sind so
viele schafe oben auf dem berg und hier
unten hinten ist auch erkennen das heißt
wir müssen definitiv erst mal die schafe
töten und schob erkennen haben ja schon
mal falls wir irgendwann so weit kommen
dass wir verzaubern können
ich habe übrigens raten ein apfel
gegessen hat mit zwei hunger dings
gegeben soll ich runter zu dir oder was
willst du da hinten denn dann ist die
scharfe irgendwie töten hier oben
gestartet oben auf dem berg sind so
viele papier kohle kohle
okay das ist dann können wir das fleisch
auf jeden fall gleich schon mal ein
break-ball machen sie es mich dann kann
man hier darüber
wohl erst die kohle noch ein bisschen
wenn wir schon mal ein bisschen
ressourcen jahr die auch uns könne
definitiv verloren
definitiv nein
ok profis dennoch hier oben herunter
okay ich schaffe damit sie dann gleich
alles wahr machen können also ich glaube
die hauptsachen unseres plans haben wir
schon mal geschafft
ich glaube wenn es jetzt noch keiner
nach gestalten nach geduld ist dann wird
uns auch keiner mehr nach sechs tagen da
noch braucht dann ja ich denke
eigentlich gesagt dass viele schon ihre
drei folgen man vorher aufnehmen darf
schon aufgenommen haben
die freiheit habe acht fleisch von
schafen von 1 wir müssen jetzt gleich
mal gucken damit uns keiner wenn wir wir
müssen ja zur taktik mäßig vorgehen
dann laden wir die folgen hoch wann
nehmen wir auch wie machen wir das alles
aber ich würde sagen demnach noch eine
folge auf oder wir nehmen hier gleich
noch weiter auf und dann müssen wir
schauen dass wir wenn wir halt so
höhenmäßig unterwegs sind
dass die leute nicht unsere höhle
nachverfolgen wer leistet ja das heißt
wir müssen jede folge oder jede zweite
folge mal wechseln kommt darauf an wie
hochladen lassen
das heute nicht machen das kann es gibt
trotzdem noch so fries die andern
nachverfolgen wo willst du hin genau
zwischen der in dem spalt durch
entspannt durch links wo ich auch war ja
da seine sehr gut
das ist echt wichtig dass wir uns nicht
aus den augen verlieren töte einfach
alles was irgendwie laufen kann
richtig viele schafe wieder so richtig
neiße werden hier von schaafs fleisch
irgendwie viel leben
das ist so gut und da sind rinderhalter
richtig nice frage ist wie lange wir
schon auf fünf minuten sie acht minuten
ich mache mir da oben einfach kenne ich
mal die tiere im wasser
wir sollten auf jeden fall gleich mal
beraten weil ich auf jeden fall was zu
essen braucht ja ich brauche auch
definitiv aus getty vermuten kann er
natürlich auch mit der steiner zu töten
was hier so wie vielleicht nur hier oben
sind auch richtig viele tiere aber auch
mops muss man da hinten auf die insel
ließ mich unten
aber heute noch richtig viele tiere
ehrlich aber dann komme ich schon aber
das ist ja auch eigentlich gold rüstung
boden schützen soll
was ja dann kommt kein risiko ein wir
haben erstmal genug fleisch also ich
habe 23
insgesamt 26 fleisch das sagst du so
einfach
ich muss auch gleich ein bisschen
fleisch essen ich hab echt nur noch
halbe leben hier
ich habe drei dinge aber ich habe jetzt
auch kohle so ein bisschen dass wir das
auf jeden fall eines neuen staates
machen
das war krieg ich habe den getötet ja
das ist fakt mich ein bisschen ab dass
da diese bogenschützen mit
gold sind die ziemlich hallodri oder
weiß wo ich bin wenn du bist du noch da
oben bin jetzt immer weiter gesunken
in welche richtung müsse weiter gegangen
einfach rechts daran vorbei wo wir die
ganze bahn unten rechts daran vorbei ich
dachte was oben bei dem dings gewesen
die nähe von diesem bogenschützen oder
sich zum einnahmen gut weil ich denke
dann mache ich jetzt auch mal ein zwei
fackeln weil ich jetzt hier auch keine
riesigen kohlestrom habe ist so viel
kohle ja hier ist echt viel kohle gerade
vor allem ist es richtig schön finde ich
in unserer höhle stehst oder summe ab
dachten dass dieser regen dann so
gedämpft da drauf fällt quasi bitte
jetzt hier gilt der bogenschütze weg
bitte jetzt okay es jedoch gerade ist
ganz nah ich habe 28 fackel davon findet
ihr auch etwas abgeben okay wenn ihr
jetzt schon zehn minuten auf das heißt
ich würde sagen die töten jetzt hier und
machen uns ein bisschen fleisch gramm
und seine band 1 und dann nehmen wir die
nächste folge auf ok kommst du musst ja
ich durchziehen du hast das ganze ja zum
stein an ich kann auch anrufen machen je
mehr fleisch ist silvester ist halt
wirklich ich hatte auch einen hast du
noch mehr kommt man mal eben schnell
noten müssen sich beeilen hatte ich
bewerte ich mit steinen
kommt doch einfach jene machen ofen wir
stets 17 meter von diesem weg kühlt das
hier live locker bruder
wir müssen jetzt hier bowler 1 und 2
perfekt 41 und ihr werdet bewerber die
chance ist es macht gar kein unterschied
dass das gerade tag ist weil es immer
noch regnet und mops trotzdem spawn und
ich hab richtig wenig oder viel ruhe so
rum ist ich habe hier immer wieder
kunden von jaspers fressen aber du
kannst du da schon mal was raus nehmen
naja ich meine sogar schwimmen jetzt
vielleicht gekickt werden können wir
einfach an der oberfläche bleiben und
danach wieder hoch gehen in der tat ein
bisschen lanxess kita essen ist schön
alter komplett voll
also wird mit hunger ja natürlich
hier ist es nun hammelfleisch alte okay
das ist nichts neues
ich setze meine sunflower hierhin sagt
brinker hier eigentlich einfachen lassen
in der offline sind oder richtig
theoretisch können wir das machen ja das
können wir erst mal okay wir haben es
halt noch zwei minuten das schon mal
kurz schauen wo wir so in etwa hier sind
ein bisschen hier rumlaufen wo wir dann
in der nächsten folge richtig wir müssen
safe in der höhle und jetzt irgendwie
alten holen
hier vorne sieht ganz geil aus da sieht
man hier noch mehr handel
ok ich weiß schon wo wir danach hingehen
da sind auch wieder so viele schafe in
der grafik böhne hier gerade hier
okay das ist dann nicht unser hobby
diese ganze pack schafe
das ist so gut dass schafe jetzt auch
fleisch gebe ja in warm war es der zum
letzten mal hat das ja jeder gedacht und
getötet doch schaaf aber da wusste
niemand dass wir noch auf der älteren
version gezeigt hatten
und dann haben gehe er kein fleisch
gegeben aber jetzt läuft täglich auch
dahinter kommen wieder zurück ließ mich
nach
ok dann damit wir jetzt auf jeden fall
zeigt sind hier in bonn prof
denn irgendwer hat dann trank auf einmal
und kommt zu an und tötet und dass es
ins und trank dass man ihn nicht sieht
in der server liste oder so schwer krank
das einfach wäre
was ich mache ja auch noch ein paar
fackeln der skelette quickly machte noch
ein paar packen bruder theo schmitz
packen rüber für judith ja ihr könnt
euch jetzt auch noch ausmachen aber ich
glaube dass er zu blöd in so einem
projekt weil wenn wir was machen was
quasi an bräuchten eigentlich wirklich
eine base sonst können wir kein
zuckerrohr wirklich anbauen
hast du zuckerrohr gefunden drei stück
habe ich das in der schon vielen
vorausdenken erst noch beim letzten war
mit ece damit so lange müsse auf jeden
fall jetzt ist halt die frage gabriels
jetzt gleich runter schilder vier
connecten wieder klickt direkt wieder
und suchen und einander höhle oder sie
machen ist ja so will ich sagen also in
dieser folge hat sich ja geplant haben
wir denn die höhle wir können ja schon
meine hülsen der vorne geguckt da
dahinter da ist wahlsonntag ja letztlich
hin weil die aufnahme ist jeden moment
vorbei dahinter das halt so ein berg und
da können wir auf jeden fall hingehen
lass mal sagen dass werden rein
theoretisch und seiner nachschauen würde
der nächsten folge dass wir uns auf
einen drauf gehen damit wir eventuell
noch ein turnier das können wir dann
spontan ich denke nicht dass ein alter
herr george und wenn es die map jet set
noch so riesig ist noch nicht das teilt
das wäre schon richtig krasser zufall
wenn die die nach zeugen direkt bei uns
sind so das recht an seiner nächsten
folge versuchen wir dann irgendwie eine
höhle zu gehen und wirklich irgendwie
ihren tieren ihren alles mitnehmen
ok es wird wieder geklickt okay wir
werden gekriegt verkehr stellt irgendwie
passend hin noch mal schön anschauen
alles kilic
ja du auf deinen kopf auf den korb drauf
wenn es euch gefallen nicht sagen lässt
eine bewertung der morgen kommt der
nächste tag denn die die nächste folge
war und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder
etwas gutes machen